now I have to ask because uh you know
Mcenroe at the end said dot dot dot for
now yeah so is this really the end of
never have I ever
so yeah to our knowledge but I mean hey
Mcenroe knows all from Princeton New
Jersey signing off
now
I loved the series finale it felt very
satisfying as a fan what was your
reaction when you read it oh my goodness
when I read it I was like this is like
fanfic but like the actual episode like
everything that I wanted to happen just
happened I think we were like why does
this have to end but also wow that that
was a really satisfying idea amazed
because every
characters
and then the last episode they tied
everything it's it's genius genius
writing I want to know what is one
secret we don't know about this show was
there like an alternate ending that you
didn't know about was there there is I
don't know if I can talk about it but
for me
I don't know if I can talk about it how
would you feel about maybe a movie or a
spin-off I've never had
ever happened if there was a spin-off it
would have to Star Trek
yeah that's like yeah non-negotiable
okay sorry like it would have to
Benjamin Norris we love you I love that
we're gonna be game for a movie a film I
think it would be cool maybe if we did
it some time from now okay in like a 10
15 year kind of thing depending on where
we all are in our careers I think that
that would be more so the way that we
would do a movie if we ever do one but
who knows who knows where we'll be and I
mean like my tree said Mcenroe he's the
one who knows Oh I thought you're gonna
say like I said Trent should still stop
so we'll get Mcenroe on the line I need
to know well I guess I should also drink
why oh I definitely had a couple Soul
sessions on your futon is it hard for
you guys to say goodbye to these
characters too oh yeah yeah I mean it's
it's like Bittersweet I think that for
us like these characters mean so much to
us just personally not even because we
portrayed them for four years and you
get connected to a character but for us
like we really love them like they're
really like we're protective of them I
think like even their story lines
sometimes like if Ben would
um so it is hard to say goodbye but my
tree and I were talking last year and
the show I think we both said sort of
found us at the right time and taught us
so much and then I think it kind of knew
when we were ready and we got to tie it
up and the writers did such an amazing
job and now it's it's got a beautiful
bow on it it definitely was a satisfying
ending but now I'm curious that you say
that is it harder to say goodbye to the
experience then that's what I was right
I I was gonna say actually for me
personally slightly different than like
more about Davey as a character but
rather it was hard to say goodbye to
waking up at 5am every day for my call
sheet you know and like I am not a
morning person but for my job I was I
was that person that was happy to wake
up happy to say hello to every single
person in the morning and like the crew
members most of which stayed with us
since the first season so most of which
saw me when I was 17 grow up to 20 years
old and then are now some of them even
coming to the premiere and get to see me
family yeah truly as cheesy as it is but
like truly and that I think is what hit
me personally the most
um but in terms of like even just the
legacy of Davey I'm not sad about that
only because I know that in the future
only more projects will come for many
other young actresses including myself
where there'll be more characters that
are just as amazing if not more I love
that right so that's a huge impact
exactly I'm excited about the impact and
personally as an actor I'm excited for
the unknown of like what's next I think
I'm still processing
um because every time I look back I like
feel different things and right now I'm
just in like a place of what a huge
blessing it was and looking back like
how grateful I am and how much fun it
was it looked like a blast looking back
and like what you realize like I think
in the moment I didn't even realize what
a game changer never have I ever was
even though I heard it all the time like
it's just in hindsight where I'm like
it really made a difference like there
are shows out there that are super
diverse and I've never seen a South
Asian lead and and this was like our my
first time like seeing that and now it's
like happening and it's great and it's
just so wonderful to be a part of that
changing wheel
I mean imagine being having the honor of
telling the story of a young brown girl
in Rage
never seen before rage is something
that's so off limits for us
um you know culture for most women but
culturally it's
so taboo and to be fully embodied
um you know there's a there's a goddess
in in in in in a culture called Kali
which is goddess of rage and she's like
so important but you know everyone but
in real life we're not allowed to have
that yeah interesting
and
a paper Journey with sexuality and and
her horniness we all experience
experienced that but we didn't talk
about it and it wasn't okay to be
perceived that way
foreign